have I not given you everything that you
wanted a chance to go back to see your
father
this is another broken family
[Music]
we need to talk
yes Norah
[Music]
yes we do
the stage is set
world's will live
world's will die
and the universe will never be the same
[Music]
[Applause]
the flash on the webisodes were told
Tuesday January 15th I'm on the CW hey
everybody its charlie we got to talk
about this new reverse flash trailer for
episode 10 on the flash obviously not
coming back till January but a lot of
the questions you have about the crisis
on Infinite Earths teaser trailer that
they released at the end of the
crossover has to do with their storyline
taking place in the future on the flash
TV show so we got to break it down of
course there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the crossover on
the video I'll be sure to name a winner
at the end of this so first big thing
Noren reverse flash are in the future in
2049 reverse flash is a prisoner in iron
Heights you see that vest that's just
keeping him from using his powers the
producers explained that this is the
same reverse flash from last year's
crossover who had after he left Barry
travelled to the future eventually got
caught thrown in iron Heights
that's when Nora comes to find him and
they strike their bargain they did say
that they would reveal what that bargain
is during episode 10 but I think it's
pretty easy to assume that she wanted to
find a way to save her father and knew
that the reverse flash was probably the
only person that could help her so she
probably sought him out and struck a
devil's bargain but like Barry said it's
all foreshadowing reverse flash
eobard thawne only helps himself nor has
already proven that she's very
vulnerable to mental manipulation she's
naive just because she wants to save her
father so badly she's willing to do just
whatever it's going to take and that's
why they developed that special time
language so what they're doing in the
future is studying how much they can
change the timeline how malleable it is
so that they can find a way for Nora to
save Barry from crisis on Infinite
Earths prevent the events foretold in
this future newspaper from happening
without also destroying the timeline for
everyone else so that's the whole big
deal like she could save her father but
it would probably cause something just
as bad to happen that's how we wound up
with the cicada situation this season on
the flash like that the main reason why
this is happening is because of
something that Nora did based on a
suggestion by the reverse-flash so we're
doing the Silence of the Lambs Hannibal
Lecter Clarice Starling Hannibal Lecter
totally escaped at the end of that story
so pretty easy to assume that reverse
flash will find some way to escape his
prison here but
that'll unfold over the back half of the
season on the flash so a lot of the rest
of their episodes together will deal
with their plant unfolding and going off
the rails but here's the big thing
though because the producers revealed in
that teaser for crisis on Infinite
Earths is happening next year in 2019
not in 2024 so the most practical
explanation for that for the
acceleration of that timeline is that
noir in the reverse-flash changed
something about the timeline this season
that accelerates that dramatically so
that everything still goes down but it
happens much much faster
there was even lines of dialogue in that
future newspaper that Nora read to
talked about reverse-flash leading an
army of shadow demons so he's a very big
figure during crisis he probably tries
to align himself with the anti-monitor
with the hopes that he'll be able to
finally achieve his goal of getting rid
of Barry Allen permanently without
destroying his own timeline so based on
burying in Oliver's interaction with the
monitor and the powers that you saw the
way he can warp reality like that
I'm sure reverse-flash would probably
try to strike a bargain with the
anti-monitor and the anti-monitor is
actually more powerful than the monitor
because in our multiverse the monitors
are an organization of people they're
like a race there's a bunch of them but
in the antimatter universe the
anti-monitor is a singular figure
there's only one of them so instead of
having a bunch of people sharing power
you have one figure wielding all power
which is why the monitor was hyping him
up as this greater threat that's even
more dangerous than what was happening
during this year's crossover there are a
couple really big easter eggs in this
trailer footage that you saw so
obviously a lot of it focuses on the
actual flash museum you see a young Nora
sitting there reading a flash comic book
with a flash action figure with a bunch
of merch in the background that's an
actual flash title from real life but
based on this shot here I can't see the
actual cover so I couldn't tell you
which actual comic story she's reading
we'll probably get a better look at that
when we see the actual episode but
obviously she grew up at the flash
Museum so of course she'd be spending a
lot of time there just reading all the
flash stories but how funny is it that
Barry's adventures in the air averse
characters the flash characters inspire
comic book creators in the future to
form a version of DC Comics then make
the comics which all these TV series are
based on in real life so that's like the
URI Burroughs of it all
the snake eating its tail which came
first the chicken or the egg probably
one of the best meta Easter eggs ever
it'll make your head spin if you try to
think about it too hard but then you see
a shot with berry and it seems like
Norah takes him to the flash Museum in
the future because you see all that
flash merch in the background there all
the voiceover dialogue from
reverse-flash seems like he's really
pissed off with Norah like it's a
continuation of the conversation they
started in the clip at the end of
episode 8 that I put at the beginning of
this video where he's like oh yes we do
need to talk Norah it sounds like she
might not be holding up the end of
whatever bargain they struck together so
he's probably disappointed in her and he
says that she's destined to leave
another broken family behind there's
probably something about changing the
timeline in it hurting other families
like leaving families broken so he's
probably trying to get under her skin
remember he's a psychopath so he's
trying to manipulate her so that he can
escape and go on doing whatever it is
that he wants to do the other really
cool Easter Egg in here too is that you
see a copy of the physical now future
newspaper with Barry with a crisis
headline that iris wrote the funny thing
about this is is that remember the one
that we've been reading is just a
digital copy of a physical print that
happens in 2024 after this all goes down
so in the flash Museum in the future
they actually just sell physical copies
of that actual issue I think iris
probably ends up winning an award for it
but because of all the timeline changes
in the 2019 crisis instead of 2024 I
love that they cut the date off in this
shot like you can't see the date on the
actual physical newspaper so most
practical explainer for 2019 crisis is
is that as they continue to manipulate
the timeline Norah obviously trying to
do it for a good reason to save her
father and reverse-flash for his own
selfish reasons they accidentally or
maybe on purpose accelerate crisis so
that this looming threat happens much
sooner than it was originally supposed
to it don't forget the other meta stuff
that's happening in real life too
because some of the arrowverse shows
will probably go off the air in the next
couple of years so I think in real life
they wanted to find a reason to
accelerate crisis on Infinite Earths
like let's not wait a bunch of years to
do our really big event let's do it as
quickly as possible so why make all the
fans wait another half a decade just to
get this in this whole plotline with
Norah and reverse flash just provided a
really
easy solution to that problem like oh
well they'll mess up the timeline and
it'll accelerate things and then we
could do Crysis next year and it'll
totally make sense but what's not clear
from all this footage is whether or not
Barre immediately learns out that she's
in league with the reverse-flash because
he would be pissed about that like even
if Nora were doing it for the right
reasons he is still never going to trust
eobard thawne during the crossover
Oliver Queen had all those comments
about changing destiny so I do think
that Nora will be successful but a lot
of it will be due to the sacrifices that
Oliver Queen will wind up making during
next year's crisis crossover so early
theory even though Stephen Amell has
already signed a deal to come back for
arrow season 8 if they get renewed and
it seems like it will it just seems like
they're trying to find a big moment for
him to potentially go out on if that's
the case but post all your theories in
the comments below do you think that
it's Nora in Reverse flash that are the
reason why crisis is happening so much
sooner
what will happen is is there was a whole
bunch of new venom deleted scenes and
post credits that just drop so I'll do a
video for that next leave your requests
in the comments below there'll be a
whole bunch more comic book stuff
happening in the next couple of days
congratulations skull crusher Pro you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for all my crossover
episodes in Easter eggs and click here
for that brand new spider-man far from
home trailer breakdown thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome see
you guys tonight
[Music]